jackal maintenant gaspard proust pour
elle est pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
ça vegas pas
ouais super type en deux mois en mer
sans ramener un poisson je vois pas
l'exploit
[Applaudissements]
et
cette semaine alors qu'est ce qu'il ya
comme un faux déjà périmé alors
premières salles de shoot va ouvrir
quand je vois pas le problème je dirais
salles de shoot c'est quoi c'est une
pharmacie sans les produits inefficaces
alors dans la foulée gilbert collard
voyez le vergès à l'aïoli propose
d'ouvrir des salles de crimes de viols
et de vols il ya un peu en retard
collard ça existe déjà ça s'appelle une
prison
internationale le mali chambon alors la
guerre est gagnée c'était un peu
prévisible quand même on n'allait quand
même pas perdre qu'on des gars qui
savent pas se dessiner tout seul une
carte postale de l'unicef
enfin le jour où on perdra contre le
mali nous restera plus qu'à nommer
duflot gouvernement
s'est déjà fait
alors en guise de victoire au mali
françois hollande s'est vu offrir un
chameau
il a pas réagir il n'a pas réagi même
quand on gagne on arrive à se faire
humilier
on a beau critiquer l'impérialisme
occidental à un moment on devrait aussi
s'insurger contre le profond manque
d'intérêt que nous portent les pays
pauvres
offrir un chameau un français ils ont
déjà ouvert un livre de géo les maliens
ils croient quoi qu'en france on a des
crocodiles dans la seine et des
éléphants dans la garrigue
non mais sans blague dans la prochaine
fois qu'un dirigeant du sahel nous offre
à chameau on devrait lui livrer illico
un jour ce pôle erp
en plus je veux dire comme symbole le
chameau un animal qui peut rester un
mois sans boire bombe ce pas on les
libère d'un tas de débiles coranique et
nous en guise de remerciement et nous
offre une gourde qui crottes quoi
je crois de façon le seul avantage cette
intervention au mali c'est que
vigipirate est en alerte maximale et ça
c'est ma vie j pirate je suis à fond
pour comme ça pour une fois que ce pays
a trouvé une façon intelligente de
fliquer les fonctionnaires de la sncf
savait comment on recrute un soldat de
vigipirate c'est on a réfléchi mais pour
toi c'est trop dangereux tombouctou
économie
alors microsoft a décidé de lancer un
smartphone bon marché pour l'afrique
on n'arrête pas le progrès reste plus
qu'à inventer l'adaptateur secteur qui
se branche directement dans le tas de
sable
culture
selon johnny la gauche encourage la
médiocrité ils auraient quand même pu
trouver une façon plus classe de dire
que ça l'avait fait chier de bosser avec
obispo et chedid
alors bon que la gauche sans courage la
médiocrité c'est une évidence y'a qu'à
voir dans quel état se trouve la droite
culture toujours alors non rap enfin je
voulais mettre sur la rubrique culture
mais le rap c'est bien plus que ça c'est
de la culture c'est aussi du sport de la
religion est pas mal de handicap
bref deux balles ont été tirées sur la
voiture du rappeur la fouine or ça s'est
passé à saint maur des fossés quoi bon
on a le bronx qu'on méritait
sa mort des fossés c'est un peu harlem
avec des magasins de moquette saint
maclou
alors y'a pas de mort d'homme ça c'est
ça ça reste du gangsta rap à la
française on peut pas tes gesticulations
d'un videur de boîte avec la logistique
du val de marne on parle d'un règlement
de comptes je me demande bien ce que
deux rappeurs peuvent régler comme
compte en france à part un dossier aux
assedic ou le vol d'un dictionnaire des
synonymes
mais je
comprends que la fouine accuse le coup
c'est vrai qu'avec le nombre de disques
yvan on se demande s'il arrivera à payer
sa facture chez carglass
[Applaudissements]
autre fait divers danièle evenou en
maillot de bain sur tf1 rôle là
oui je ne commente pas la télé mais
quand il ya des vraies infos je pense
qu'on peut pas passer à côté sur
l'émission s'appelle splash le concept
avancé des célébrités de premier plan
qui plonge dans une piscine bon on a mis
une piscine parce que si on l'avait mis
une cuvette des chiottes les vedettes se
serait peut-être douter de quelque chose
dans splash c'est un peu la bouche à les
goûts télévisuels du has been
franchouillard quoi c'est vraiment du
recyclage à côté le loft c'est une
émission d'arte écosse
alors moi j'avais un autre concept ça
s'appelle bim bam boum c'est comme ce
plh mais avec une piscine vide
sport
football alors révélation d'une vaste
affaire de matches truqués alors il
paraît que ça concerne pas la france ben
c'est normal vu le niveau intellectuel
bon joueur c'est beaucoup trop complexe
à monter
ses pattes
je sais que ça fait un peu cliché
d'illustrer cette idée par une photo de
ribéry mais je vous jure il suffit
d'écouter 15 secondes pour se rend
compte qu'en fait non c'est possible
alors cette révélation s'accompagne de
forts soupçons de dopage dans le milieu
du foot pas en ligue française s'est pas
allons tu m'étonnes celui en france pour
tenir le coup c'est pas celui que tu
joues un match qui doit se doper c'est
celui qui le regarde
high tech
récemment la police a découvert 50 mille
images pédophiles dans l'ordinateur d'un
commerçant à toulon alors bon le tipi
s'est défendue la durée mais bon j'ai
consulté des sites une ou deux fois elle
aurait pu trouver autre chose contre moi
quand je consulte en ligne mon compte à
l'ubs est ce je me retrouve pas avec
50000 photo de jérôme cahuzac à poil
sordide ce bébé mort dans le ventre de
sa mère faute de place pour le faire
accoucher à la maternité alors c'est
vrai que c'était a beaucoup mobilisé les
gens très triste les un petit mais
pourquoi pourquoi la couche mince et une
ligne à tout ça le truc classique quoi
et ben moi j'ai compté le nombre de mois
qui séparent l'accouchement de l'acte et
j'en suis arrivé à la conclusion qu'en
terme de karma ce n'était pas idéal de
copuler le soir de l'élection de flamby
alors peut-être une bonne nouvelle pour
terminer il y en a une vraiment la
vitesse sur le périph la passé de 80 à
70 km heure chouette on va enfin pouvoir
profiter du paysage
alors
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de l'ina
l'institut abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus